this is the consulate in Hong Kong where
Simon Cheung works today his face was on
posters start to its rules instead Hong
Kong residents handed in a petition for
the UK to do more to secure his release
Hong Konger are doing our duties England
expects that every man will do his duty
and now save Simon now a friend mr.
Chung's had a meeting with the deputy
consul general it's always been the case
that the Beijing authorities would like
to randomly detain people and well the
approach is not surprised but the person
they did think surprised man
Simon Cheung travelled from Hong Kong to
the city of Shenzhen on mainland China
for a business trip on the 8th of August
he traveled on the Express rail link on
his way back to Hong Kong that day
according to his family he sent his
girlfriend a message saying ready to
pass through the border pray for me at
10:40 p.m. mr. Chang's family say they
sought assistance from the Hong Kong
police and the immigration department on
August the 9th but the first
confirmation of his detention only came
today from the Chinese Ministry of
Foreign Affairs and even at that very
first mention Beijing linked mr. Chung's
case to the UK's diplomatic efforts over
the Hong Kong protests he is not a UK
citizen he's Chinese so it's entirely an
internal matter for China so with regard
to the mistaken comments the UK has made
on Hong Kong China has openly expressed
its position and made stern
representations to the UK once again we
want to urge the UK to stop making
indiscreet remarks and stop stirring up
trouble on the Hong Kong is you mr.
Chung is being kept in what's called
administrative detention in Shenzhen
he's under suspicion
the Chinese say of violating public
security management regulations the
crucial bit is what happens when that
administrative detention period ends on
Friday that's when 15 days are up the
best option then is that Simon Chung is
deported back to Hong Kong
the worst option a criminal
investigation that would be an ordeal
for mr. Cheung but also be a big test of
British diplomatic skill law is there
any end to the protests in sight this
gathering at a metro station tonight
just the latest the UK government has to
navigate all of that and now with the
safety of one of its employees on the
line - Tom Cheshire Sky News Hong Kong